digamos que tenemos la función f de x
igual a coseno de x al cubo esto también
se puede escribir de esta otra forma
como coseno de x entre paréntesis
elevado a la tercera potencia y queremos
encontrar f prima de x lo que vamos a
hacer es aplicar la regla de la cadena y
vamos a verlo un poco con más
profundidad para tratar de hacer una
conexión entre lo que estamos viendo
aquí y lo que puede llegar a ver en tus
libros de texto de cálculo así es que si
tenemos una función que está definida
esencialmente como la composición de dos
funciones y observa aquí en esta función
estamos elevando una cosa a la tercera
potencia aunque no estamos elevando
simplemente una equis a la tercera
potencia sino una función de x también
lo podemos ver de esta otra forma
estamos tomando la función coste no de x
este coseno de x lo estamos metiendo en
otra función que lo que hace es elevarlo
a la tercera potencia y también lo
podemos explicar de esta otra forma
tomamos una equis como entrada de la
función coseno aunque ya aquí tenemos la
función coseno y ponemos la equis como
entrada y eso como resultado nos da 12 9
x y luego a eso lo vamos a usar como
entrada en otra función que lo que hace
es simplemente tomar toda la entrada y
elevarla a la tercera potencia y
entonces qué es lo que vamos a obtener
bueno pues aquí tenemos que elevar a la
tercera potencia pero qué es lo que
estamos elevando a la tercera potencia
pues estamos recibiendo como entrada a
coseno de x entonces elevamos a coseno
de x a la tercera potencia por lo que
ésta es una función compuesta a esta
función azul le podemos llamar la
función b
ya ésta le podemos llamar la función y
así es que estamos tomando la equis y
dándosela como entrada a la función y
por lo que esto de aquí es q de equis y
luego estamos tomando todo esto y de x
como la entrada de la función b y
entonces esta salida tiene que ser b de
la entrada pero la entrada es de x así
es que aquí tenemos b de o de x esto
también lo podemos escribir de esta otra
forma como ve de coseno de x porque y es
la función coseno y b es una función que
le des la entrada que le des la eleva a
la tercera potencia si es que si le
diéramos simplemente una equis vdx sería
x al cubo pero aquí le estamos dando
coseno de x entonces tenemos cosas 9 x
al cubo y ahora
si tenemos una función compuesta que se
puede escribir como la composición de
dos funciones como hicimos por acá
entonces podemos aplicar la regla de la
cadena aquí estamos diciendo que f de x
se puede escribir como la composición de
b con luke y ya sé que lo estoy
repitiendo muchas veces pero cada vez lo
explico un poquito diferente porque pues
la primera vez que ves estos temas puede
llegar a ser un poco complicado y
difícil además cada vez entiendas con
mayor profundidad qué es lo que
realmente está pasando por aquí entonces
vamos a seguir escribiendo esto de
distintas formas
fx es la composición de ve con y
entonces se puede escribir como be
compuesta con q y evaluada en x y la
regla de la cadena nos dice que si
tenemos una situación como ésta
entonces la derivada f prima de x y esto
es algo que va a saber tal cual en tus
libros de texto de cálculo
derivada de fx es igual a la derivada
con respecto a v x o sea de prima
evaluada en o de x por la derivada de de
x con respecto a x osea q prima evaluada
en x y listo esto de aquí es una de las
expresiones de la regla de la cadena
pero ahora como la evaluamos en este
caso en particular bueno podemos empezar
por usar los mismos colores esta función
que simplemente eleva a sus entradas al
cubo la vamos a colorear de azul ahora f
prima de x otra forma de expresar la
connotación diferencial también voy a
escribir las varias veces con la
anotación diferencial pero podemos
empezar por aquí como la derivada de la
función b
con respecto a la función u y de hecho
eso es justo lo que tenemos aquí en este
término pero nos falta multiplicar por
la derivada de y con respecto a x que
hoy aquí tenemos que poner la derivada
de q y esta parte es justo este término
de aquí en algunos libros te lo vas a
encontrar de esta forma con la notación
diferencial y en otros de esta forma
pero este término de aquí es justo este
término de acá y este otro término es
este término de acá pero bueno ahora sí
vamos a evaluar estas cosas seguramente
ya estás un poco aburrido de hablar en
puros términos abstractos
así es que esto va a ser igual a por
aquí vamos a tener la diferencial de una
función con respecto a otra y vamos a
estar multiplicando por una diferencial
con respecto a una variable pero bueno
y estamos tomando la diferencial de la
función b con respecto a u pero aquí la
función be evaluada en nu
el coste no de x elevado al cubo
seno de x elevado al cubo y estamos
derivando con respecto al coste no de x
y queremos multiplicar esto por la
derivada de v con respecto a x pero u es
el coste no de x y estamos derivando con
respecto a x y bueno esto ya lo hemos
visto antes nosotros ya sabemos que la
derivada con respecto a x d
con seno de x nosotros ya sabemos que
esta derivada es igual a menos seno de x
así es que esta parte de aquí nosotros
ya sabemos que es igual a menos seno de
x tal vez estés más acostumbrado a ver
esta anotación de esta forma realmente
quieren decir lo mismo a mí me gusta más
esta porque me queda más claro que
estamos derivando la función coseno de x
con respecto a x simplemente es notación
pero ahora que es esta cosa que tenemos
aquí bueno pues lo podemos ver de esta
otra forma si yo tuviera la derivada con
respecto de x de x a la tercera potencia
si tuviéramos esto y bueno déjame pongo
por aquí unos paréntesis para que esté
un poquito más claro que esto sería
igual a 3
por equis elevado a la segunda potencia
ahora la noción general es que si estoy
derivando algo elevado a la 3 con
respecto a ese algo y por cierto ese
algo puede ser cualquier cosa podría ser
color amarillo de hecho ni siquiera
tiene por qué ser una equis puede ser
una pelotita por aquí estamos haciendo
la derivada de el círculo naranja
elevado a la tercera potencia con
respecto al círculo naranja pues eso va
a ser igual a tres por el círculo
naranja elevado a la segunda potencia
aunque bueno aquí estos círculos son
amarillos verdad entonces vamos a
ponerlos de color naranja estamos
derivando el círculo naranja elevado a
la tercera potencia con respecto al
círculo naranja y eso es igual a tres
por el círculo naranja elevado al
cuadrado y entonces si en lugar de
círculo naranja tenemos coseno bx y
estamos derivando
el coste de x elevado a la 3 con
respecto al coste de x
entonces esto nos va a quedar igual
a 3 por el coste no de x elevado a la
segunda potencia elevado a la segunda
potencia y observa aquí lo que estamos
haciendo es derivar a la función
exterior con respecto a la función
interior entonces vamos a obtener lo
mismo que tendríamos si aquí tuviéramos
una equis pero en lugar de una equis
tenemos coseno de x por lo que en lugar
de ser 3 por x al cuadrado ahora tiene
que ser 3 x coste 9 x al cuadrado sólo
sustituimos x por coseno bx y luego la
regla de la cadena nos dice que si lo
que queremos es obtener la derivada con
respecto a x sólo nos falta multiplicar
por la derivada de coseno de x con
respecto a x como aquí y ya casi
terminamos ya casi encontramos la
derivada la derivada es esto
por esto efe prima de x es igual a menos
-3 3% o de x seno de x por coseno de x
al cuadrado coseno de x al cuadrado y
listo ya terminamos aquí estuvo un
poquito largo porque también estábamos
explicando cómo funcionaba la regla de
la cadena pero una vez que te
acostumbras a ella lo puedes hacer
rapidísimo lo único que tienes que hacer
es derivar a la función exterior con
respecto a la función interior lo que
hay tratar a la función interior como si
fuera simplemente una equis y entonces
lo que nos queda es tres por la función
de adentro al cuadrado
cazenove x al cuadrado y luego tenemos
que multiplicar por la derivada de la
función de adentro con respecto a x o
sea simplemente tenemos que encontrar la
derivada de coseno de x
pero eso es menos seno de equis y listo
ahora sí ya terminamos